it's business as usual for these
fishermen in the Thai province of punga
but on this day 15 years ago a tsunami
triggered by a magnitude nine point one
earthquake devastated the coastline here
waves as high as seventeen and a half
meters came crashing in from the ocean
killing nearly 5,000 people in this
village alone with half the population
wiped out nearly everyone who has lost a
relative or even a friend nowand
chantara Wong knows too well that no
matter how many years have passed the
pain of losing your children never goes
away
I don't think they died on the day the
tsunami hit we couldn't find them until
the 28th and their bodies hadn't
decomposed at all I often imagine how
much they would have thought about me
before they took their last breaths but
we couldn't find them we couldn't help
them this is stuck with me and every
time I think about it it hurts
these images shocked the world the day
after Christmas
shortly before 8 a.m. in 2004 the
earthquake struck under the sea in
northern Indonesia it rippled across the
Indian Ocean triggering a tsunami that
hit dozens of countries in Asia and
along Africa's East Coast getting close
to 230,000 people and it happened during
peak tourist season the majority of
those who died were in Indonesia entire
villages were flattened and the carnage
of that day is still fresh on the minds
of those living in at Chopra vents the
worst hit area where a hundred and
seventy thousand people were killed on
behalf of the government and people of
akshay today we formally want to thank
more than a hundred and fifty countries
that have been involved in helping
rehabilitation and reconstruction no one
knew the tsunami was coming on that day
there was no early warning systems in
place but it was a global lesson learned
[Music]
since then more than four hundred
million dollars has been spent across 28
countries on detectors survivors say the
technology is not enough though and that
public awareness and education are
necessary to save people's lives
Zaara hayaat al-jazeera